New claims coming from Russia's
invasion of Ukraine.
The Russians are claiming just minutes ago
that there are Ukrainians
operating on the Russian side
of the border inside Russia.
We'll have much more on that
in just a moment.
In the meantime, Ukrainian
officials are saying they still hold on
to some neighborhoods inside Bath Move,
which is that city in the Far East.
The Russians claimed to have captured it.
It has been
one of the most hotly contested
cities, the bloodiest
battlefields of the war in Ukraine.
Ukrainian
President Zelensky mourned the devastation
there over the weekend.
Mr. President,
this is less news,
but we're still in Ukraine's hands.
The Russians say they take about one
I think no,
but you have to understand that
there is nothing.
They destroyed everything.
There are no buildings.
It's a bit it's tragedy.
But for today,
a moment is only in our cars.
All right.
CNN's Sam Kiley is in southeastern
Ukraine.
Sam, back to what
we just reported a few moments ago.
This claim from the Russians
that Belgorod, which is this city
over the border
from Ukraine that we showed on the map
a number of times,
just over the border from Ukraine.
They say there are Ukrainian saboteurs
operating in and around that area.
What can you tell us
Well,
the Ukrainians say, yeah, you're right,
except they're not Ukrainians.
They're Russians.
And they're saying indeed that
and the unit themselves
have put out a video saying that they are
involved in this cross-border operation
because they're members of the Freedom
from Russia Legion,
which is a group of Russian volunteers
who are in the Ukrainian armed forces.
They have in the past been fighting.
When I encountered them back in December,
they were fighting very heavily
as south of parliament on the front line
there.
It now
appears that they have crossed into Russia
with an all Russian team,
according to the Ukrainians,
and the Ukrainian government
is saying somewhat coyly
that they are operating there
entirely as Russian
citizens, as free agents,
not as part of the Ukrainian armed forces.
Although, of course,
they're using Ukrainian uniforms,
weapons, bullets and arguably vehicles.
Now, that spokesman
or that the member of their political wing
here in Ukraine has told CNN
that the combat is ongoing.
And certainly social media would indicate
from a number of videos
that are being posted
that they have deployed themselves
in a number of villages
very close to the border.
This is the first time that we have
confirmation from the Ukrainians that,
let's say a Ukrainian backed organization,
military organization, has conducted
overt military action against Russia
inside Russian territory.
We've seen in the past covert
military operations
deep behind Russian lines here in Ukraine
and indeed mysterious activities
inside Russia itself that have even been
helicopter gunship attacks
close to the city of Belgorod
in the past that the Ukrainians
have refused to acknowledge.
But this is a first. John.
Yes, and let me just point out
on the map here
so people can see
if we keep talking about it,
this is build a road right here,
right over the border from Ukraine there.
And a first, as you note,
a first of the Ukrainians confirming that
at least at a minimum,
pro-Ukrainian forces are operating
inside Russian territory.
Sam, calling it significant development.
We'll come back to you in a bit.
Thank you. Let's bring in retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons. It's
good to have you as always.
So let's begin
there because Zelensky saying
not for
sure, the buck has fallen to the Russians.
Russia,
the volunteer group is saying it has.
Why is it significant?
Not strategically,
but began to watch propaganda.
That's all it's going on here.
This is the twilight part of this battle.
At this point, there's
no nothing tactically more to be gained
that the city has been flattened.
Fundamentally, it's more or less.
It shows Ukrainian resilience,
but also Russian military failure.
They're trying to claim some kind of
victory right now that just isn't there.
So also a shift in the Biden
administration's
views on F-16s over the weekend.
Right.
At least greenlighting joint
training of F-16 pilots
with our European allies.
Why is that significant?
Because as you know, The Wall Street
Journal editorial board very critical
that it's taken this long.
They write about it.
The obvious question is why
this decision took 15 months.
Yeah, well, a couple of things.
First of all, let's be clear
right about this.
The F-16s are not going to be game
changing to the situation on the ground.
It's not going to give air superiority
to the Ukraine military.
There's going to be a very long time
before
they're actually going to be impactful.
I think it took that long
because from a strategic perspective, now
you're going to see Ukraine eventually.
And NATO's
this is really kind of a fait accompli.
Now because of them getting this platform.
So because of fighter jets,
not previous weapons like Mars, etc..
Now, this is a strategic weapon.
So like, for example, he Zelensky tells
President Biden he's not going to attack
into Russia because the F-16 gives him
that capability,
hard border right around between
Ukraine and Russia here.
There's targets in Belgorod.
There's air base targets here, missile
sites along along this border here.
There's multiple sites
that the F-16 now has capability to attack
that cross that border and that
that violates that's where that from.
These weapons were supposed
to be defensive, now become offensive.
Looking at the countries where it's likely
that the F-16s would come
from the United States, what?
So I think these four countries are
the ones that likely give up the F-16s
they have in their inventory
as they transition to F-35s.
Norway, Denmark,
the Netherlands and Belgium,
maybe
30 to
60 or so F-16s in the next few months.
It's still going to take
a significant amount of time.
Three major issues
here. We've got to train pilots.
We have to make sure the pilots
are up to speed on what's going on.
That's going to be four to six months.
And it's it's a surmountable challenge
right now.
But maintenance and sustainability of
these is going to be a key.
There's some spare parts
that they're not even made anymore.
Lastly,
what are the munitions going to look like?
What are those
airframes are going to be on them
because the F-16 is a platform,
does a lot of different thing.
Note it, this pilot training is a reason
why a number of members of Congress,
actually Republicans were calling
on the Biden administration
to start the training Earlier,
in case we got to this point.
Let's talk
about what was signed overnight.
The president
had to cancel his leg of this trip
so he didn't go for a first ever
what would have been a historic visit
first American president
to go to Papua New Guinea.
But Secretary Blinken went.
Yep. And overnight
they have come out with a joint
defense agreement, a maritime agreement.
Can you speak to the significance of that,
given
the rising influence of China
in the region?
Yeah, a big win for the administration
diplomatically.
Papua New Guinea is a location right
north of Australia.
That provides tremendous place
for the Navy to project power
from naval assets.
We saw the Chinese make deals
with the Solomon Island countries
before there's going to be
this pivot to the Pacific
that's finally now taking place.
I think it's very important
that this administration
did that very big win
for the administration.
Thank you, my clients.
Great
to have you as always, Major. My client.